today I'd like to tell you how I became
a scientist I decided I wanted to be a
scientist when I was 9 years old I
actually think that I didn't decide I
wanted to be a scientist I decided that
I wanted to continue to explore things
take them apart see if I could put them
back together part of the reason I
became a scientist was because of
something that my uncle said to me he
had a master's degree in chemistry and
he showed me one day a paper that he had
written that had just appeared in a
journal of chemistry it had some title
that made absolutely no sense to me it
was long and I had these figures in it
and he took the paper and he said to me
this was easier to write than an English
paper that made a big impression on me
because papers were not easy to write so
that was intriguing I think the other
thing that got me started was that my
mother had told me she wanted to be a
botanist she was very interested in
plants and how they worked but as a
child she had gotten rheumatic fever
mr. year of class was promoted an extra
year ahead and she kind of never caught
up with arithmetic and mathematics to
her credit when I was 13 my mother went
back to school took a class in
statistics which was very difficult but
she did pass the course and that taught
me something about the importance of
persistence and have not been afraid to
do the things that you want to do when I
got to college actually it was when I
was in junior high school I went to a
program that the National Science
Foundation had it was called a summer
science training program and kids in
junior high school got together at a
college campus and we got to do
experiments and listen to lectures it
was a wonderful summer it was in a small
campus in Tyler Texas the campus
organizers bought me the book calcify
Laxus
I had read a Reader's Digest article
about Hans Elia who was interested in
the stress response in an
in humans and so I bought his textbook
which I mostly did not understand I
don't remember much about the
experiments except that I did take out
adrenal glands and followed the rats
I took the rats home with me by the way
many of them got away and there were for
many areas you could find black and
white rats in the neighborhood now and
then so that kind of solidified my
interest and what a wonderful thing
science might be it was really fun it
was a group effort that we had at the in
Texas I made very good friends there and
I felt very satisfied that I was doing
something with both my brains and my
hands that was very satisfying so when I
went to college I wrote to someone at
the University of Washington which I was
where I was thinking of going and asked
how do you become a physiologist which
is what Han celeea was and he told me
that as an undergraduate I should go
take I should major in chemistry so I
went off to the University of Washington
it's the only school I applied to and I
applied there because I had an uncle in
Seattle
well chemistry was pretty hard and
although I'd been a very good student in
high school I found myself struggling
and so about midway through the year I
went to my adviser whose name I can't
remember for the life of me I'd like to
remember it because I'd like to
embarrass him and I told him I was
having difficulty in introductory
chemistry and he said well of course
you're having trouble chemistry's not
for girls being a freshman and not
knowing any better I said oh okay and I
went and changed my major I went through
five majors in my first two years as an
undergraduate I went at from chemistry I
went completely outside of science into
history didn't like that because the
first class was really big and it pretty
boring actually then I went found the
history of medicine which was extremely
interesting and I found then there that
library work looking into magazines and
history could be as another exciting way
of exploring things and I almost did
that but there was really only one
person who was doing that at the
University of Washington and you know
you were really sitting by yourself in
the library most of the time I then went
back to biology and
had the very good fortune to take a
class that was given by Robert Kahn it
was the only time the class was given
because it was very expensive and
unwieldy to give for undergraduates in
the class we used radioisotopes we were
in the lab 24 hours a day taking turns
in sleeping bags following experiments
as we went we also had visitors visiting
scientists who came in and treated us as
serious people who wanted to listen to
their results one of them was John
Gurdon that was a surprise to me because
we had read Gordon's papers and they
were very important papers in the field
and so I had envisioned him as an older
man with gray hair and glasses because
that's what a scientist looks like right
of course I was wrong I was impressed
with how young he was this redheaded man
full of energy and fun who obviously
delighted in telling us about the
experiments he had done and the way in
which he had come to his conclusions
that kind of solidified my interest in
developmental biology that question of
how from a single cell you end up nine
months later with the human being who
grows up truly a remarkable miraculous
series of events and how that exactly
happened is of course one of the most
interesting questions that still stands
before us we've learned a lot but we
don't really have the whole picture yet
so I decided to do developmental biology
I asked my professors how I should go
about this and they told me I had to go
to graduate school so I said okay now
there was one small problem during those
years when I was having trouble with
chemistry I was also discovering the
joys of a social life and I was going
out with a lot of people and I was
skipping classes and so forth so my
grades were shall we say a little
erratic well about that time I met a
medical student that it or really what
happened is he tripped me in the law in
the cafeteria in Seattle
we went out he had to make up for
tripping me after all and we got
together and it looked like that was
something that might last
but then he was going to go off to do
his residency on the East Coast so I
asked my advisors about schools on the
East Coast where he would be and since
he was going to be in Bethesda they said
why don't you go to
Johns Hopkins I couldn't go to Johns
Hopkins because that was an all men's
school at the time dates me a bit so I
ended up at Goucher College which was a
close by in the sister College in all
woman's college a very good college for
me because it was very small very
different from the University of
Washington and I got a lot of attention
from the professor's including one of
them found me a job for the summer at
NIH in the laboratory of Loretta levy
who was a molecular microbiologist and
who introduced me to the concept of
molecular biology she pretty much taught
me everything from how to hold a pipette
to the fact that you really really have
to have small stretches of dialysis
membrane if you don't want them to get
all tangled up in the stir bar in the
flask
she was the person who would be writing
references for me when I was applying to
graduate school I applied in Boston
because that's where my husband my then
husband was going to be as a doctor well
I applied to every school in Boston
except MIT loretta asked me why I hadn't
applied to MIT and I said I hadn't
applied to MIT because my vision of MIT
was a bunch of guys running around with
slide rules doing math and I was not
fond of math and I wasn't very good at
it either so she looked at me and she
said you have told me that you want to
do developmental biology and molecular
biology if you want to do that you have
to apply to MIT because that's the best
program in the country right now so I
applied to MIT and it's a good thing
that I did because MIT is the only
school in the Boston area that accepted
me that was an important lesson you will
not get anything that you do not ask for
you will not get anything that you don't
apply for so do it just apply for it
getting into MIT was one of the best
things that ever happened to me it was
an extremely exciting place to be a
graduate student or scientist MIT is
really graduate student heaven the the
science that was going on was remarkable
the faculty considered us their junior
partners we were talking all the time
about something interesting going on and
learning all the time
I worked there with David Baltimore and
Harvey loutish who had very different
but complementary approaches to science
and to taught me a lot
developmental biology wasn't there
wasn't somebody in that department that
I wanted to work with who is doing
developmental biology so instead I did a
joint project with David Baltimore and
Harvey Lotus that used biology that
David was doing and protein synthesis
cell free protein synthesis that Harvey
was doing and I put them together I was
the first student at MIT to have a joint
PhD advisors and it was a interesting
way to do it and very useful except for
the part when I started writing papers
for a while there I would take my paper
to one of them and they would make
suggestions on it and then I would take
it to the other and they would reverse
the suggestions so I finally took two
just going directly between the two of
them before we got the first paper out
David and Harvey were extremely good
mentors for me for different reasons
they expected a lot of their students it
was there that I learned that hard work
can be extremely fun especially if
you're working with a group of other
people we worked hard and we played hard
and we learned a lot and those people
are still very good friends and close
colleagues today after graduate school
the question was what do you do next and
I wanted to go back to developmental
biology so I began was listening to
seminars I heard photos casados give a
talk on the silk mop as a model system
for studying protein synthesis in a
developing system so I went to talk to
him arranged the postdoc and then I went
back and told David and Harvey that I
had my postdoc all set up to my surprise
they were both very offended and it
turned out that they were offended
because each of them thought that I had
gone to the other for advice and help in
setting up the postdoc and I learned
then that part of the job of a good
scientist is to mentor the scientists
that come after them the people that
they are training and they took that
very seriously I also found out later as
I interacted with other people but often
the busiest scientists are the best
mentors they're the ones who are working
the hardest
the ones who have the most connections
and they're the ones that it is
worthwhile being persistent about
getting to and talking to and learning
from I learned a lot in photos lab
including the power and the value and
the pain of failure things had worked
very well as a graduate student I got
six papers out had a lot of experiments
did a lot of collaborations with people
not only at MIT but around the world so
when I got to photos his lab and things
didn't work that was pretty tough to
take in addition that was the time when
the recombinant DNA controversy was all
in full bloom and for those of you who
might not know that was a time at which
there was a fear that if you took DNA
from one source and connected it to DNA
from another source and then put it into
a bacterium or a yeast or anything like
that
you might create a new creature that
would be super dangerous germ or
somesuch
never very credible scientifically but
it had a lot of force socially and what
that meant for me in particular was that
I could not do the science I wanted to
do in Boston it was banned in Boston and
Cambridge and so I went to Cold Spring
Harbor with Tom Mooney Otis and with a
couple of his graduate students and
postdocs and I spent a summer in Cold
Spring Harbor trying to do something
which in retrospect was not possible
which is to clone a very large genome
into a plasmid which is a small piece of
DNA I like to think that maybe that
failure encouraged money on us to think
about the phage packaging system which
he developed shortly thereafter I
returned to Harvard with no positive
results from a year at Cold Spring
Harbor that was very discouraging at
that point a friend of mine I get a sex
try the oddest who was in photos lab
came to me and said I'd like you to work
on this project with me and Wally
Gilbert we're trying to clone insulin
actually what I said is we're trying to
clone insulin arch was quite a character
he had been a Shakespearean actor in
Greece had a medical degree from Greece
but when he came to the United States he
decided that his as he said the MD from
Greece is useless so he entered the ph.d
program
and was working on his graduate degree
with photos that project led to a
probably the most interesting project of
my scientific career first of all
everything worked that practically never
happens in science it was six months
from the beginning of the project until
the publication of that paper that paper
and many others that were published
during that time led to a new direction
for many biologists it led biologists
from the bench directly into the real
world of business and and applications
of their science something which had not
happened before but that's another story
that perhaps will approach another time
you